hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see tend not to see I
identity thief so let's hang out Ryan's
consensus there are no reasons to watch
identity thief there are no reasons to
watch identity thief the director of
Horrible Bosses uh made a horrible movie
get it [ __ ] hate that dude stop
Jerry's consensus I'm not just say that
identity thief is the reason movies I'm
just I'm just kidding with it sits there
aren't any reasons to see this movie
there are no reasons to see identity
thief throughout most of the films just
kind of sitting there going who let this
happen reason to see number one there
aren't any there aren't any reasons not
to see annoying characters there's a
comedy out there that is annoying this
is the definition of annoying by far
well it's tedious you start out with
Jason Bateman and you know you're just
watching a nice guy have a crappy day
then he crashes into melissa mccarthy
who is an [ __ ] and then he becomes an
[ __ ] too and that everyone is an
[ __ ] so it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
until the third act where the movies
like oh crap we have to have some heart
out i know this guy's barely in it but
even John Cho now that I look back on it
what an [ __ ] that guy was it's like
you just recruited this guy from your
heart and now you're like hey man [ __ ]
the whole identity thief problem you got
going on yeah well there were two
pleasant characters in this movie one is
big Charlie who's weird but he's at
least not a bad guy two is the hotel
clerk who calls jason bateman on being
in a hospital the weird thing about it
though is the actors seem committed to
the performances they are committed to
the
performances actually I guess the
material just makes them so annoying
maybe that's why it's that annoying is
because it's the actors are believable
so you just kind of want to punch
everybody it doesn't seem like Jason
Bateman Melissa McCarthy just showed up
on set like there are some honorable
mention moments I yes there are some
moments that are good when when it does
finally ram a heart down your throat at
the end there are some moments for like
oh if this would have been great in a
movie where this made sense I think that
you know Jason Bateman Melissa McCarthy
the word is palpable they have palpable
chemistry it's too weird to see that
like you know they actually have a good
back-and-forth going on but it's so
annoying to watch the thing about
Melissa McCarthy's character is she's
not one of those characters in the movie
who you know like oh she's annoying to
everyone else but the audience thinks
she's so funny yay no she does such a
good job at this character that she too
is annoying you so much when you're
watching the film well and then Jason
Bateman's [ __ ] material makes him so
much more annoying well and it's it's
it's a weird push-pull because you get
why he's being an [ __ ] and you can
identify with why he's being an [ __ ]
but for some reason it's like after a
while it's like dude quit being in it so
yeah and the other thing is that they
gave they get into all these situations
work if he would just go I'm transported
her to Colorado she stole my identity
like a half hours worth [ __ ] would
have been say that and then it's like
they get all these really good people to
show up for cameos and it's like why are
you in this movie and why are you not
taking advantage of the their caveat man
like I they save John fakhro built build
is like what like third hey you're one
seeing that's a really short scene I
know picture comes back later though
they do have a photo I feel like they
cut out like a lot of his scenes or
something you know there were times
where I felt like stuff was cut reason
not to see number two it's not funny
it's astonishing people are like dude
identity thief is like as like I was
prepared for
full movie and I you know it's nothing's
ever as bad as people say it is I have
never been in a comedy where I didn't
laugh and I didn't laugh I laugh
probably I could count the amount of
times I've laughs that's how few up at
times I actually laughed it's on one
hand I chuckled like chore or five times
I don't I never cracked up once you know
yeah I never laugh I chuckled like four
or five times and all like supporting
characters for like random throwaway
lines like his little things but like
it's kind of like you're awkward friend
at your party who keeps tell who's like
got all the energy so it's awkward each
telling a joke and they're just jokes
not hitting and then you're like I I
should have left there that's where they
want me to laugh but it's not funny half
the jokes are she's fat he has a girl's
name everybody in this movie does their
thing for two hours it's mean-spirited
but it's not fun at all like it it's a
mean-spirited comedy but and I want to
call it like offensive I know I mean at
the same time it like even the cops are
[ __ ] like the good everyone's an
[ __ ] that's like the world they
provide you with is just a bunch of
[ __ ] who you believe to be [ __ ]
and so it makes it not funny and then
they have like uncalled for serious
moments that start occurring close to
the finale where you're like this there
should be more comedy at this point why
is this so serious well they seem to be
doing what I was afraid they would do
which is like they're giving Melissa
McCarthy like the exact same career that
Zach Galifianakis had coming out of the
hangover yeah it's like due date all
over it yeah exactly a reason not to see
number three bad writing and directing
talking about it is draining me just
it's tedious because it's it's so it is
draining experience to sit through you
know like the everything about it seemed
to be sort of a ripoff of other comedies
it seemed like it was trying to be like
Midnight Run but it doesn't even do a
good job of ripping them off you know
i'm all for familiar premise or whatever
like that but at the same time they
could have taken way more advantage
would the premise they had instead of
turn into some they got this great setup
and I thought was the smart set up you
know it's the financial world this guy
deals with it you know he's one of the
smartest guys in the world but yet they
set him up at the beginning like he's a
[ __ ] idiot so the premise that
promise but then they just turns it to
some stupid roadtrip comedy out of
nowhere well yeah it's like they spent
all this time setting up like I said
it's a nice guy having a shitty day that
just keeps getting shittier and that
stuff is it all that funny but at least
for the first 20 minutes or so like it
works like you're with it and then when
it turns into a comedy just it's all
down hill like it's shocking it this is
from the same guy who directed horrible
bosses and a bunch of other like he's
done like like documentaries he's done a
few other movies that are all like
reasonably good and interesting so you
don't expect you know realism out of a
movie like this but you gotta be able to
believe its world and it it's not like
nothing is believable because everything
is it's like every seam follows a
different set of rules and then when
everyone comes together everything is so
convenient at the end that it undoes
like anything that could have worked
like and not to mention to its is the
longest comedy ever made it is so long
either I'm not talking lengthwise it
feels an hour longer than when you hear
the legs are like no [ __ ] way you
gotta be kidding me it inevitably is
much longer it's under two hours and it
feels like two and a half it really does
go it's the never ending movie you're
watching it going I'm so annoyed what is
this movie's gonna end I never walk out
of movies it's humbling I never walk out
I was this close to suggesting to my
friend that we're gonna walk the [ __ ]
out of here as I asked her like are you
and I asked like an hour and are you
really annoyed at this movie and she
admitted that she was also an okay Jim
it's a very annoying film see I can't
blame you for wanting to walk out it
lasts man forever yeah I mean for me
it's like I wasn't oh I wasn't gonna
walk out but I was
kind of sitting there the whole time
going further and further and just like
how how did this happen like how do all
these things go wrong like who wrote
this script like what is Oh what's so
funny too is when I watch this movie
when the screenwriters name came up
there were clearly three rows of people
behind me Beverly yeah yeah yeahs house
like have you guys read the reviews for
this movie so far you don't know what
have you seen this movie yeah yeah like
dude now this is a pretty awful [ __ ]
film oh oh it's a bummer it's a yeah no
I can't recommend it has no idea how to
take advantage of its cast has no idea
how to take advantage of its premise its
character set of a lot of things that it
has well set up it has no idea how to
take it to the extent that it deserves
yeah it's like what happens
subscribe subscribe and tell us your
reasons to see or not to see identity
thief if put is how the simpler reasons
to see identity thief yeah yeah I will
gladly battle you on the internet and
talk to you about why your reasons I
don't agree actually and you might be
surprised I'm very open-minded guy you
might might open my mind to I than
anything you could next week Ryan Wright
could be like this is the best movie of
the year mm-hmm now subscribe